they won't even know what it is that i
need to know that they know but if i
listen very carefully i can kind of call
it out of them and then i can use that
information to correct myself so i don't
do something catastrophically stupid in
the future and hurt myself and the
people i love
and so you have to have this presumption
of
this presumption of ignorance
and
that the belief that the person across
from you particularly if they differ
from you
might have something useful to say
because they're different from you they
know things that aren't that you don't
know so isn't it so good that they're
different and then you have to believe
that
men of good will exist let's say and
that they can exchange information
that's mutually corrective and both can
walk away
better
and that's something like faith it's
faith well i think it's equivalent i
think it's equivalent to in the
christian sphere it's equivalent to the
faith in logos
it's it's the same thing
and logos is a very complicated concept
one of the reasons and i'm not quite
sure
why this is the case but one of the
reasons this
theories of everything podcast has taken
off the way that it has is partly
because i'm not averse to this
ambiguous contradictory thinking when it
comes to metaphysical issues like
whether or not there exists a god and to
speak in terms of religious terms most
scientists are as you know and as i know
most scientists are
they find that to be anathema and i i
don't hey i'm going to talk to richard
dawkins oh well that's wonderful
yeah i saw your conversation with
lawrence krauss and i was well i have
yeah i did another one with harris too
just a week and a half ago and it went
real well i figured out how to do to
talk to sam better than i have before i
just asked mostly i just asked him
questions and that's really useful to
just to ask questions rather than
because i think i went sideways to some
degree in my discussions with sam which
i don't usually do
i was trying to prove something sideways
well
well i
like i said i was trying to prove
something instead of listening and
asking questions and i should it would
have been better had i not tried to do
that and just tried harder and harder to
understand
what it was that he thought
because one you know the more we talked
the more we found like real major points
of of agreement
you know like sam is oriented
to a great degree he's very much
concerned about the human tendency for
atrocity and malevolence
that drives him
that terror of that and that's i would
say that's my fundamental driver i hope
it is at least
and so that's something that really
unites us and he's hoping that he can
find
you know a genuine morality now he
believes he can find it in scientific
inquiry and and i don't think that's
true but whatever he might be right and
it's not like i don't think science can
inform our moral choices and maybe has
to
but
i tr you know when i came out on the
public sphere and first talk to sam
i had this axe to grind in some sense
which was my belief that the fundamental
framework from within which we see the
world isn't and can't be objective and i
still believe that's true but i i was
hammering at home because i wanted to
win that argument and that was that
wasn't the most sophisticated way of
going about it well less and less i
think as we talked
so and this time i didn't do that at all
i just asked him questions and we
definitely had the best conversation
we've ever had